hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to anyone
who knows me knows I love trailers and
how can't you there's supposed to be
everything that's amazing about the
movie in two minutes with fast editing
clever scene choices and music that's
almost never actually in the film the
trailer can sometimes be better than the
movie itself I bring this up because two
very big trailers with very different
reactions came out recently one being
kept in America Civil War with the
reveal spider-man
any other being ghostbusters with the
reveal of some really lame jokes you can
guess which trailer had which reaction
but this does bring up a good question
how right are the trailers don't get me
wrong
Ghostbusters reboot cool could suck and
Civil War could be amazing but we live
in a world now where we do our reactions
just based on the trailers help this is
technically a video on the videos on the
reaction to the trailers we've become so
obsessed with media and film that
sometimes there's even a trailer for the
trailer it's kind of weird
maybe our love for how cool trailers are
is growing or maybe we're just so
excited to judge something as soon as it
comes out technically before it comes
out it's no secret we all really like
doing this but why it's clearly not the
movie is just an advertisement for it so
why do we get so sucked into them is it
because it's fun yeah a little bit
here's the thing everybody knows
trailers are supposed to be manipulative
so it's interesting to see how well we
figure out just from two minutes if an
entire hour and a half plus film is
going to be good it does how keen we are
at spotting an obvious trick or locating
a beneficial product how cool is it to
get hyped up for the dark night trailer
and have it fulfill your expectations or
twiddle your fingers at how little they
show up The Return of the King trailer
because you know they're keeping all the
awesomeness a secret it's also fun to
look at something like gem and laugh at
how obviously off they are capturing the
original source material sometimes good
movies and bad movies are pretty easy to
spot
but the fact is not every good film has
a good trailer and not every bad film
has a bad trailer some of the worst
movies have phenomenal trailers remember
the suck gas Mario Brothers movie the
teaser is incredible no I'm not talking
about that shitty I got the power one
that was the first sign something was
wrong
I'm talking about the this ain't no game
trailer that may look like Batman meets
Total Recall
that
where's the rock the plumbers took it
it don't look like the game but it
looked pretty badass but as we all know
it didn't turn out to be quite bad how
about cats and dogs which I recently
reviewed the trailer looked kind of
funny maybe this could be a cute idea
but as we all know it didn't turn out
that way son of my mom yeah the same
thing can be said for movies that look
really bad but we're actually kind of
good Pixar has a long line of trailers
that usually look off a lot of people
thought Toy Story was gonna be a huge
bomb based on its advertising but lo and
behold it set the standard for most
animated films nowadays the teaser to
frozen was so bad and so misleading the
Americans were actually watching the
Japanese trailer because it looked more
awesome and now today that's much closer
to how the film is marketed the
importance of trailers now has never
been so strong you naturally want people
to be talking positive about your movie
but sometimes even bad talk if it's the
right bad talk is a good thing every
time a new Transformer trailer is
released everybody rolls their eyes and
complains about it but it also racks up
the views causing more people to talk
about encouraging more people to check
it out the new Ghostbusters for example
it's probably gonna be a hit because
well as much as some of you don't want
to see it you're just so damn angry you
have to see it to see how it compares to
the original what do the changes they
make say about how they're treating
something you love are you open to the
change or do you feel they should leave
good enough alone but then some bad talk
not surprisingly can hurt a film to the
backlash on the choices of the last
Ninja Turtles movie were so great that
they actually changed the casting of
some of the characters around oh and
didn't you hear
that's Lex junior in the new Batman
Superman movie just like it always was
right even the new Star Trek trailer got
star writer Simon Pegg to come out
publicly and say this isn't the movie I
wrote the ads featured a more rock fan
action stunt flick that star trek of
ideas the paga sure's everyone that that
was marketing's choice he guarantees
them the film is much different
in fact trailers can be so manipulated
that some have even been recut for
humorous purposes to the most popular
ones are shining and scary married to
movies seemingly switching tones as
shining is recut as a feel-good romance
about embracing life and Mary Poppins is
recut as a supernatural horror film the
great thing about both of them is
technically neither one lies shining is
about a writer who's trying to get away
and has trouble connecting with his
family he's a writer looking for
inspiration lots of ideas goodness Mary
Poppins is about a strict nanny with
shocking superpowers we all laugh at
this because we know through clever
manipulation something we're all
familiar with can suddenly be
transformed but that again shows how
misleading trailers can be and how even
though there are a lot of fun to analyze
and get excited for they're not always
right
keep in mind half the time when these
trailers are released the movies aren't
even done yet and we're just given
random scenes that they're supposed to
turn into something incredible if you
ever see a scene in a trailer that
seemed out of place it's usually because
it's one of the only scenes available
and they weren't given much time to
figure out how to make it look cool I
find a good way to figure out whether a
film is going to be good is look at the
scenes in context of how it would fit
the film people were shocked at how bad
Batman and Robin was when it came out
but if you look at the trailer and think
of it in context of how these lines and
visuals would fit the film the warning
signs were all there come join me my god
amazed
she loves me not you and he's driving
you crazy this is why Superman works
alone how could you make any of this
work in a serious Batman movie you
couldn't something like the trailer to
Iron Man looks good though because the
setup is drawn an egotist genius
stripped of everything forced to find
his humanity again and with great
effects in humor it's a juicy story that
opens up a lot of conflict and
development even with new films though
you can't guarantee always being right
you can kind of utilize this too
spider-man in civil war seems like a
good idea but we know it's not about him
and on top of that it's a different
Spider Man from what we saw before this
means they probably won't have as much
of him in the film as you think despite
them ending the trailer with him and
even if they did they wouldn't have
enough time to establish him to a point
where you'd want to be rooting for him
chances are this is probably a slightly
longer cameo in a movie and won't have a
starring role nevertheless that's what
everybody is talking about the most and
are excited for the most even that lame
looking Ghostbuster trailer does have
some potential when you really think
about it the character lineup of the
nerd the squeamish the wild card and the
badass could actually create some good
comedy those gadgets are kind of like
being allowed to punch a ghost or blast
them with handguns and as fake as the
ghosts themselves look they do kind of
seem creative almost like the
Ghostbuster cartoon or toys maybe it'll
be something so new it'll work well
maybe it'll be something so lame that
nobody can get on board for it seeing
how trailers have so often not given us
what they promised they're going to give
us we can never know for sure we can't
act like we can predict from the start
whether or not we're going to like a
movie everyone has had a surprise they
didn't think they would like everyone
has had a film they disagree with
critics on and everyone has head of film
where you come out saying wow that's not
at all what I thought I was gonna get
from the trailer no that doesn't mean
don't analyze trailers or see what makes
a good one or a bad one
assumptions aren't always as bad as
everybody thanks they help us make
rational guesses and spend our time well
as long as we realize they are just
assumptions and not facts there's lots
of good trailers - bad films I love
watching to get my blood pumping even
though I know the film isn't
good and there's lots of films I adore
with all my heart despite the fact that
they were marketed falsely trailers are
fun to watch fun to analyze them fun to
speculate over we need to know though we
won't always be right and there's no
foolproof way to tell what we're going
to like and what we won't I thought I
would hate films like Kung Fu Panda Toy
Story or cabin in the woods but I ended
up loving them I thought I would love
films like mana steal Wolverine x-men
origins or signs but they sucked hard
maybe you had the exact opposite
thoughts of me and you thought these
trailers perfectly summed up the movie
whatever your thoughts they are exactly
that thoughts their opinions on things
that aren't factual and that's what's
gonna make them so great everybody has a
different one so everybody has something
new to offer so keep talking about your
trailers try to figure out if you think
they'll be good or bad but just remember
if people laugh from embarrassment at
the first Star Wars trailer when that
came out I think it's safe to say just
about anything is possible
except this your thoughts were right
about that I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Cystic Fibrosis Foundation cystic
fibrosis is a life-threatening genetic
disease that affects the lungs and
digestive systems of approximately
30,000 children and adults in the u.s.
more than 10 million Americans are
symptomless carriers of the defective CF
gene but this is the leading
organization committed to finding new
therapies and ultimately a cure to this
disease if you look at their website and
their YouTube page you can see all the
great leaps and bounds they're making
and how many people they're helping live
normal lives again even Louis black one
of my comedic heroes backs this
organization you can see his video on
their YouTube page right now if a guy as
awesome as that is backing this up you
know it has to be a good place with so
many stories and so many improvements
being made you can see right in front of
you all the fantastic work that they're
doing so what are you waiting for click
on the link and see if you can help them
find the cure
you